they ignore that I feel I feel
and you can't you can't you can't even
have a discussion with feelings a
perfect example is like some of these
like Kevin Samuel kind of videos where
he got famous because of he said someone
was average at best this woman was below
average by the way it was being nice
but he was like
your average at best because she was
either you know the whole talker I've
got a business you know I want a higher
value man this woman looked like a llama
fan but she was like your average at
best and then he was he was called a
hater he was like oh you're beating down
women I was like why is telling someone
that you look like a normal person an
insult yeah it's because yeah when did
that become an insult average most
people are average narcissists are
always special though foreign
I was thinking about it this morning I
had a conversation with my husband I
figured it out I had a lack of that's
why I started this YouTube channel keep
going keep going I was just I started
this YouTube channel so your theory is
so most modern women are narcissists why
um because they think about it this way
you're a female right you've grown up
your whole life being told you're the
center of the world every film is about
romance every action film The superstar
has to get a woman some woman somewhere
um now this whole feminist thing so you
don't have to be accountable now it's
just like well there was oppression you
know something happened to Victorian
woman 10 years ago that kind of thing
that's why I can't do this facts um you
can you know and then there's this whole
like believe women think this like you
don't you don't have to be accountable
to anything so of course you think
you're God if I get more too many
compliments a day I think I'm good
imagine if you were getting compliments
and told you incentive Universe from
birth and then people were saying hey
man yeah get married What is marriage
until a man takes care of you
that that's why they're narcissists the
whole dating game is phenolphus you take
them out you caught them right there's
no idea of quoting for men because men
are told they're dispensable women are
told they're the prize it just it just
reached that mismatch now where they
have so much power and Men also kind of
been beaten down by you know technology
and all the things that happening right
now that we can see it but women have
always been narcissists outside
but and I think there's something to do
with the education system in the UK as
well because I've had two relationships
where as soon as I got a degree I could
see the change straight away straight
away yes the same day they got that
certificate that says you wouldn't go
bucket or whatever and then what
happened what did it teach you this uni
but that's ended you have to end it why
because the women because what happens
is when a woman starts out earning her
husband she tends um she tends to
divorce him if you don't bring me a
piece we're done what happened is she
got a good graduate job and then she
thought she would get a better amount of
KPMG on Central London and that's what
she's done
um it also happened with me in Portugal
I met this gorgeous Portuguese girl and
as soon as she came to London she
switched up I met her I was like hey
what are you doing I'm selling oranges
what do you like to do I like to sleep a
lot you have a dog that's that what do
you want to do I want to be an air
hostess as soon as she came to England
in University now she's doing this this
whole like aggressive like attitude
black girl thing I was like oh you know
I only want peace now I don't want to
deal with anyone
she as soon as she got in this country
so what you're saying is as soon as
women get an education oh my goodness
that's it get rid of them you can't
that's what you're saying no no no no no
you're not saying you're looking to be
offended like when you say this like
you're looking to be offended that's
what they're saying they're saying women
act like they're better than you once
they get an education
what kind of question is that like if
you're if like not in a not in a like as
in like I'm better than you you're less
than me as in like as in like you're
bringing more they're bringing more to
the table now so you know but that means
nothing to them so like like guys don't
care about your education they don't
care about your income they just want to
know that you're hot hot feminine okay
let me let me put the picture so you met
this girl and she doesn't look she
doesn't got a job right so you then
support her so she goes on and get that
degree now she's got the degree she
hasn't got a job yet right so she got
degree now she's looking at the
potential I'm going to end this on this
month you know what you've been there
before she got a paper now she then said
okay I've got this degree now so I can
do this listen and then I should change
completely if it's not easy to get along
you should not isn't stuck to anymore
in the world are we doing together then
it's just ego bro yeah I'm thinking if I
go and get your degree and I'll get
three on the wall and go over there look
the problem isn't actually the education
it's actually the isn't the people we
don't know we live in a system where
feminism has been glorified and as a
result that coupled with education
causes women to act a certain way a
quote from C.S Lewis he said that
Education Without values only serves to
make a person a cleverer devil so if the
foundation
if the foundation is that you know
there's a wrong mentality of you know
Independent Women boss baby all of that
stuff and then you add a layer of
competence to it now I have more
ammunition rather to not to add value to
my relationship but to fight in my
relationship power so basically that's
what it is it's that wrong Dynamic
they're building from the wrong
Foundation basically but education isn't
the issue like you can have a smart
woman yeah
some of the dumbest girls I know are
educated though like I think honestly
like I prefer people that are less
educated because I think they're smarter
because like I think I literally think
college teaches people to be idiots in
what way in what way because it's like
they get indoctrinated even in schools
like I remember oh my God like I in my
college I was an economics major and I
had a teacher that was telling you that
the reason that
um like prices were higher in poor
neighborhoods because they like didn't
like poor people basically like that's
indoctrination because the reason prices
are higher in poor neighborhoods is
because they steal more and usually the
distribution is more expensive so that's
why the prices go up it's just stuff
like that like they they teach you
propaganda in schools another example of
that I I used to date this uh feminist
German girl I and she she and she was in
King's College right one of the best
universities in the world
um she was taking this class so she was
just sending me this stuff from the
class it was about like um eco-feminism
this idea that women we destroyed the
environment because the environment is
like Nature's Gaia which is a feminine
it's a goddess right and so that's
another way of defacing the feminine and
that and that you know and that's men
toxic masculinity extended to like our
choice and like toiletries that men like
shampoo that smells like masculine
things and like grenade shaped soap and
that that was an example of toxic
masculinity and she was like mocking men
and saying people are so dumb this and
that and I was like bro I have a grenade
soap what's wrong with grenade you have
a problem with the shape of myself now
this is like a like a a woman with like
Top Class degrees on a scholarship from
Germany as academic as possible but also
not not the sharpest in the Box in some
ways and and like the other thing is
they we have women's studies how sexist
is that why do we have women's studies
we don't have men's studies what's
what's women's studies you've never
heard of like gender studies women's
studies yeah but women are complicated
though so I couldn't understand that
women are not complicated but I don't
know what they want no they just lie a
lot they're not complicated just if you
watch what they do women are not
complicated at all I agree with that
like I refused
how do you explain this a woman gives a
relationship advice and then she goes
and do exactly the opposite yeah because
she's playing you for a donkey she's
testing whether you're the man in it if
you ignore if you do exactly the
opposite of what she says she'll
actually be more attracted to you
because she's more familiar with you now
and you've shown you have balls
everything they say is a test you know
it's just lies like you just made up
like like women will try and convince
you that they they wear skinny clothes
because they just enjoy when I'm skinny
clothes they'll try and convince you
that like paying for them doesn't mean
anything but then they'll demand it as
well and then dance to get into it
they'll try they'll try and claim that
like you know they like equal
conversation and it's fun I I will check
your hinge profile right now watch who
you're interacting with and I watch how
much that guy has been saying and I
guarantee you it's the guy that said not
very much he's probably very good
looking though
you're just spitting facts today
the devil is a liar okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna Read Super chats for a second guys
um all super chats go towards um updates
in the studio we're also trying to save
money to get a bigger place next year we
want to do all different types of
content so I'd like to do like like
dinner talks where you eat dinner and
like discuss a different idea
um and so
so the money that you guys send is going
towards our rent next year and that's
why right now memberships is so
important because it really helps have a
state a sustainable source of income
um that can we can use every month